climate change is
the looming crisis behind covet
and we are really excited that
president biden rejoined the paris
agreement on his
very first day in office and i'm sure
a shared transatlantic commitment to a
net
zero emissions pathway by 2050
would make climate neutrality a new
global benchmark i also commend
president biden's initiative to host
a climate leaders summit on earth day
because now is the time for action
this is also true when it comes to the
digital world
and the impact it has on our democracies
at its most basic we want to make sure
that what is illegal offline is also
illegal online and we want clear
requirements
that internet firms take responsibility
for the content they distribute promote
and remove today i want to invite our
american friends
to join our initiatives together
we could create a digital economy
rulebook
that is valid worldwide a set of rules
based on our values human rights
and pluralism inclusion
and the protection of privacy a new
global agenda
a more globally oriented us and a more
capable europe this is how we can tackle
the challenges and
europe is ready for this